don't rise
but another episode of chicken watcher
in Santa Monica day we got quasi took a
watch we got my brother Brian of
authentic Caribbean Oh No but today we
are in Caribbean chicken in our search
for the best fried chicken in the world
Lacey
yo what part of the Caribbean do you
hail from or does your family come from
sure your dad Trinidad what's the
coolest thing you've ever done in
Trinidad
[Music]
play steel drums that's pretty cool oh I
love you my steel why don't they call it
a silo bowl all right Keith well let's
head to cha-cha chicken on chicken is
the cha-cha dance a thing that you guys
do am I totally crazy James don't
cha-cha dance who are you and where are
we you at the spa cut up chicken
chacha-ji way up in here to try some of
our famous coconut fried chicken just
like you came in with a dance we provide
that dance for it's on your palate are
you feeling the sand between your toes
palm trees and sunshine and everything
you know in the records is the rest you
know maccalister you talk for days yes
this is lovely
we do all these amazing other chickens
chipster chicken wings tata chicken so
it's not one particular Caribbean
no no no see so we took a little cube in
a little gym a can a little Puerto Rican
little Mexican we just kind of mix it
all up like Bob Marley someone love you
know so yeah welcome I'm sold
yeah that was greatest pitch I've ever
heard and I'm gonna say that and I'm
gonna say on chicken watch well I'll say
chicken watch together all right guess
it's time yeah we're all going to yeah
whatever you want to do with the show
yeah she killed for the chicken for that
chicken hot murder it's just Chris and
to have Erzberg a crazy [ __ ] that's
crazy
we got energy though we ain't too lazy
we watch flooded chicken chicken lunch
[Music]
mm all right learning to cook cha-cha
fried coconut chicken take one and how
do you prepare that chicken it goes
through one day marinating process
citrus orange cinnamon cloves allspice
jerk spice it's been marinated for a day
then they get seven roasted and then
from there gets braised in the kind of
like sauce so it's roasted and then you
put the breading in exactly right I like
to have it soaking in a little bit of
coconut milk so we're gonna put a little
bit of regular all-purpose flour into
our chicken just to get it started there
in the flour you're putting into the
flour we add coconut shavings in with
the milk we got chicken on chicken on
chicken on ticking we go through about
three or four shavings week of about a
thousand pounds of chicken 5,000 5,000
pounds of chicken we can't get it either
become fast enough to serve that's a lot
of chicken and we're just dunking in
there for about six minutes and you get
a nice crispy texture and like a nice
soft tender chicken inside Wow good it's
there memmer had fried roasted chicken
I've never eaten a chicken batter off
the chicken before wow that was
different than most of our what kinda
look like cauliflower you guys ready to
get into oh my god yeah so good look at
this cha cha real smooth okay question
where are you going oh man chicken watch
[Music]
all right we got our tropical drinks our
coconut fried chicken
Cuban fries rice and beans where should
we dig in Keith wait to the left now
y'all that's my brother Brian I'm haha
chicken Frank all right let's see the
chicken thank you God thank you God
thank you God
yeah we actually haven't had a ton of
fried chicken that in anyway lens sweet
the chicken itself has a really mellow
sweetness right but it's not like that
when you have coconut shrimp that really
sweet kind of hitch over the head with
coconut flavor the outside just has this
tiny bit of sweetness the inside is
crazy flavorful it's like usually you
just got one little hop of flavor but
now it's two hops this time yeah ChaCha
we're very critical if somebody that's
trying to do with the cuisine of the
islands of our homeland we take a more
kind of open approach here where it's
like the flavors are vast and this is
like the whole vibe in there it's like
it matches with the food all in all some
really good fried chicken man mm-hmm
texture of the chicken meat is like
velvety I'm a huge fan of the crunch
yeah that is brought on by the coconut
the souq rasa tea is it's delightful
oh just try the straight-up skin it's
like a little sugary wow that's really
good so I can say it's a very sexy sexy
sexy nod
we haven't seen that once in all of
chicken watts
where the chicken gets baked and then it
gets fried to be honest when he said
that I was like is this still gonna like
be a really moist chicken or is it gonna
be like overcooked it's not overcooked
don't worry good chicken technology
still allowing it is so much more in my
nose than normal who's that mean kind of
nuts coconut go nuts
haha guys let me interject once more I'm
glad you guys are loving the chicken the
great thing of all of this is like once
you're here once you're having the
chicken with us once they're drinking
this nice drink listening to some nice
reggae got the plantains going up the
recipes going on everything starts to
make sense
[Music]
[Applause]
and life is beautiful and these flavors
that I was telling you about you see
this little warmth in this Stalin GI you
feel like you're home you feel like
you're on vacation vacation chicken
right here we go sure so this is what
it's all about it's relaxed some shelves
yeah you can kind of feel the sand
between your toes smell the salt in the
air little dolphin jumping out of the
water
give me a sick I 5 spitting the water
out of its hole coconut fried chicken
just hang in it
am I gonna move to the Caribbean Oh guys
everybody clap your hands everybody up
your head Wow thank you Oh turn it up
our big question is in this the best
fried chicken in the world this is the
best fried chicken in the world I mean
is there a best fried chicken fried
chicken at its core is like the best
thing ever on its own everybody has
their own different renditions of it I
shouldn't like to think that you know my
rendition of this chicken is a beautiful
amazing thing it's one of my favorite
but I would leave it up to you guys is
there a best fried chicken in the world
yeah how do you stop to think about that
before I ask the question about which
one was the question we always have to
ask ourselves as was this the best fried
chicken in the world but you know we
heard a better question today is there a
best fried chicken in the world I think
you might have liked some chicken more
than I like some other chicken and five
minutes six chefs said there is no best
chicken everything yeah it's all on your
personal private or must be that one so
it's yes the Indian I'm a cha-cha for
the cheap
[Music]
Oh guys this has been a really wonderful
season you know I'm glad we could end on
vacation I feel like we deserve it
we've put in a lot of work traveling the
world via Los Angeles yeah that's funny
I want to eat fried chicken I get happy
that's like the closest I get to a
meditative state is what I'm eating
fried chicken so you guys are gonna hang
out after this is shows all over hope so
I hope so
I won't see you everyday I can't go back
to my normal life I've not eaten fancy
fried chicken every day I'm just down we
can still do it we'll still hang out
we'll still get chicken
even without the show even without the
show look the show is just a reason to
hang out and eat chicken with you
[Music]
[Music]
I think that's good right taking watch
check it watch see you next time take a
watch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell is going on between the
sheets and litter at home baby wait
Kwai see James don't touch our dance
[Music]